just setting up a zoom meeting for
anybody in our marriage that would like
to join us and we're gonna do is she
gone
we're all featuring our soup chicken
call gossip at all
I'm just in a zoom meeting I've got Lisa
and Claire I'm myself and Claire's gonna
do it what do we call it Claire Kiki
how'd you sitting here having a really
nice session at qigong message was right
to do what's not right to do I've just
had an email from me city council saying
and their message was stay at home if
you can which was just like confusing
not struggling with the situation should
not be in black and white and not
knowing what the right thing to do is
this week has definitely been a bit of a
change at home my husband's gone back to
work he's reopened the fish-and-chip
shop it's been quite hard it's a bit
quiet around the table today because the
baby's gone to sleep and my husband
isn't home you know he was helping out
with the children which enabled me to
then go and do any work that I needed to
do within the wider community
how are ya but this is drop deserve some
fish and chips off home with shop I've
been able to try lots of new things like
baking cake we both enjoyed that do you
think you'll carry on doing this a lot
though probably I mean thing is I've got
my therapy
just come home from work and the girls
are gonna agree